On the 16th of August, 1660, an approximately
70 year old William Harrison walked toward
the village of Charingworth, about two miles
from Chipping Campden, with the intention
of collecting rent for his employer, the Lady
Viscountess Campden.
When he failed to return home, Harrison’s
wife sent out their servant, John Perry, to
find him, but neither man returned that evening.
Becoming more alarmed, Harrison’s son, Edward,
went looking for his father and Perry the
next morning, and finally found John Perry
on the road to Charingworth, but the latter
explained that he had not found the elder
Harrison.
The two then set out to Ebrington where they
found tenants Harrison was to have visited
and learned that Harrison had, in fact, made
contact with them, but no sign of him was
otherwise found.
That is, until William Harrison’s blood-stained
collar, hat and comb were found along the
road.
Seemingly at least partially owing to John
Perry inexplicably not returning the night
he went out searching for Harrison, suspicion
soon fell on him and rumors started that he
had murdered his master.
When first interrogated, Perry explained the
reason he had not returned that night was
because he got lost.
You see, when first ordered to go out into
the night to search for Harrison, Perry claimed
he was too scared to do it owing to it being
completely dark.
Thus, after a brief walk about, he instead
went and hid in his master’s hen house.
Around midnight, however, the moon came out
providing enough light to search by.
But in the process of searching, a mist descended
causing him to get lost.
He then went to sleep under a bush for the
night and resumed his search the next day,
at which point Edward Harrison found him.
He otherwise claimed he had no knowledge of
what had happened to the elder Harrison.
The magistrate being unsatisfied with this
story, Perry was detained while further investigation
could take place.
Approximately a week later, with little progress
in the case, Perry was subjected to additional
interrogation.
Initially, he stuck to his story, but later
changed his tune.
It’s important to note here that it may
be that subsequent interrogations were of
the strong-armed variety (as was very common
at the time), or he might have simply been
scared he’d be tried for murder so wanted
to shift the blame to anyone else.
Whatever the case, during the subsequent interrogation,
Perry supposedly intimated that a Tinker had
killed Harrison and later that he knew a servant
of an unnamed Gentleman had robbed and murdered
Harrison.
In yet another interrogation after this, Perry
finally cracked, claiming that his mother,
Joan, and brother, Richard, had waited until
Harrison had finished collecting rents and
then robbed and killed him, dumping his body
in a pond.
He even gave a detailed account of the event,
including his own involvement in it, telling
his brother when to expect Harrison and where.
He also stated after Harrison had been attacked,
he encountered his mother, brother, and the
unconscious Harrison.
To quote the confession as recounted by magistrate
Sir Thomas Overbury in his 1676 account of
the event,
At which he told his Brother, he hoped he
would not kill his Master; who replied, Peasce,
Peace, you’re a Fool, and so strangled him;
which having done, he took a Bag of Money
out of his Pocket, and threw it into his Mother’s
Lap, and then he and his Brother carried his
Master’s dead Body into the Garden, adjoining
to the Conygree, where they consulted what
to do with it; and, at length, agreed to throw
it into the great Sink, by Wallington’s
Mill…
He then stated his mother told him to return
to his master’s house to see if anyone had
grown suspicious of Harrison’s absence.
He later claimed to have taken the bloodied
hat, collar, and comb, slashed them with a
knife and then placed them along the road
so it would be assumed Harrison had been robbed
and murdered there.
When brought in for questioning, Joan and
Richard Perry denied the entire story, and
although the pond was dredged, no body was
found.
As Joan and Richard did not have an alibi
during the night in question and John Perry
seemingly would have no reason to implicate
himself in murdering a man, all three Perry’s
were arrested for the murder of William Harrison.
However, owing to the lack of a body or clear
evidence that a murder had taken place at
all, the presiding judge in the case, Sir
Christopher Turner, ultimately refused to
prosecute the three for murder.
That said, about a year previous, the Harrison
household had been robbed of £140.
Given John Perry’s assertion that his family
had been continually pressuring him to rob
the Harrisons and that they themselves supposedly
had intent to do so, John Perry was questioned
about the former robbery.
He then affirmed that his brother had committed
the robbery and, while John himself wasn’t
directly involved in the act, he had told
his brother where the money was kept.
After stealing the money, it was supposedly
buried in Perry’s garden with the intent
of digging it up during the next Feast of
Archangels, long after most would have forgotten
about the robbery.
The timing of this meant that the money should
still have been buried in the garden when
John Perry was confessing this, but when the
garden was searched, no money was found.
Interestingly, despite no evidence whatsoever
that the Perrys had robbed the Harrisons the
year previous other than John Perry’s assertion,
and despite that Perry’s mother and brother
denied that they had done this, all three
pled guilty on the robbery charge.
Why?
Well, as for John, he’d already implicated
himself as an accomplice, so it was natural
enough that he would then plead guilty.
His mother and brother were a different matter.
They initially pled not guilty, but within
minutes of this changed their plea to guilty.
It appears they were advised to do this and
to ask for a pardon under the Indemnity and
Oblivion Act of 1660 as a time saving measure
for the court.
In a nutshell, this Act was a general pardon
for anyone who had committed a crime during
the Civil War and Interregnum so long as said
crime wasn’t unlicensed murder, rape, piracy,
witchcraft, sodomy, or bestiality.
Thanks to this, if the three pled guilty and
asked for a pardon, they would not receive
any punishment whatsoever and the court wouldn’t
have to waste time in attempting to prosecute
the case.
Thus, they pled guilty and were immediately
let go.
This act likely cost the three their lives.
You see, when Harrison still hadn’t turned
up by the spring of 1661, it was decided that
he must have been murdered.
Because the three had pled guilty to robbing
Harrison previously; Harrison had been known
to have been carrying significant rent money
on the night in question; at least John Perry
had known this fact and the route Harrison
would be taking; and Harrison’s bloodied
items had been found, it was decided there
was sufficient evidence to try the three for
Harrison’s murder.
Despite proclaiming their innocence, the judge,
Sir Robert Hyde, and jury didn’t buy it.
The three were convicted of murder and hanged
together in Gloucestershire on Broadway Hill.
Since Joan had also been suspected of being
a witch, she was, naturally, hanged first
in the hopes that any spell on her sons would
be lifted by her death, allowing them to confess
to the murder.
But in all three cases, the trio, including
John, professed their innocence right up to
their short drop and sudden stop.
John even recanted his former story, saying
he made it up and actually knew nothing of
what happened to Harrison.
And, it turns out, they were telling the truth.
Approximately one year after they were hanged,
William Harrison returned to Chipping Campden
alive and well.
So where had he been all that time?
He claimed that he had been robbed and kidnapped
by two men on horseback.
During the ensuing melee, the elderly man
also claims to have been stabbed in the thigh
and side.
After this, he states he was sold for seven
pounds to a group who dealt in human trafficking.
He was then placed aboard a ship to presumably
be sold into slavery.
It was while aboard the ship for an inexplicably
long six weeks that he was nursed back to
health.
However, in route to whatever destination,
the slave ship was attacked around North Africa
by Turkish pirates, who then took Harrison
and the rest aboard and sold them into slavery.
As for Harrison, he claims to have been sold
to an elderly doctor in Smyrna (modern day
Izmir, Turkey).
His time as an assistant to the doctor was
cut short, however, after only about a year
when his new master died.
After this, he claimed that he used a silver
bowl his master had given him to gain passage
on a Portuguese ship returning home.
In Portugal, he encountered a fellow Englishman
who took pity on him, providing him money
for food and passage back to England.
As you might expect, while this sort of kidnapping
wasn’t totally unheard of, the idea of someone
choosing to kidnap a man about 70 years old
at the time of his abduction (so little value
on the slave market, even if not near death
from being stabbed) is generally considered
a bit suspect.
Certainly the rent money he was carrying would
have been worth the robbery part, but the
trouble and additional risk in transporting
and selling him to the slaver group wouldn’t
have been worth the seven pounds they supposedly
got for him.
Because of this, it’s speculated that perhaps
he simply skipped town with the money he’d
been collecting for his master and left his
bloodied items behind to make people think
he’d been killed.
However, the aforementioned Sir Thomas Overbury
notes that this seems unlikely given the elderly
Harrison was reasonably well off in his current
profession already.
He also hadn’t taken any of the considerable
sum of money he’d himself accumulated over
his lifetime.
On top of this, he was well respected and
had a good reputation around town, including
having always seemed happy with his station,
even up to his disappearance.
Sir Thomas does speculate that perhaps someone
hired the supposed kidnappers to attack Harrison
and get him out of the way, explaining why
such might bother to kidnap such an elderly
individual in the first place.
Sir Thomas thought the prime suspect in that
scenario would perhaps be Harrison’s son,
hoping to get Harrison’s job, though even
this is a bit of a stretch given the known
facts of the case.
Curiously, a couple weeks before Harrison’s
disappearance, there is record of John Perry
reporting being attacked along the road by
two men wielding swords, though he ultimately
managed to escape.
During his later interrogation for murder,
however, he changed his story and said he’d
made the whole thing up with a mind to use
the story to remove suspicion from himself
and his family when they later would rob and
murder Harrison.
Whatever really happened, despite magistrate
Sir Thomas Overbury noting that at least some
at the time thought Harrison’s story farfetched,
there doesn’t seem to be any record of anyone
interrogating him further about it and he
was also given his old job back and resumed
his duties.
As you might imagine, the fact that the justice
system had executed a trio of people for the
murder of William Harrison when he hadn’t
been murdered resulted in a bit of a public
outcry.
It’s often stated that, as a result of this
injustice, the English courts instituted a
new criminal rule “No body, no murder”-
a law that supposedly stayed in place for
some three centuries after, being rescinded
during the 20th century.
However, we could find no such record of any
such specific “no body, no murder” law
being instituted and there are certainly plenty
of cases of people being convicted of murder
in England in the interim when no body was
found.
Any such law would also have created a huge
loophole to relatively easily get away with
murder- you’d just needed to be really good
at hiding the remains, which wouldn’t have
been difficult.
For example, for a time things like medical
schools and the like would not only pay you
for said body with no questions asked, but
generally keep quiet about everything and
dispose of the body themselves in a way that
the remains wouldn’t be identifiable.
(This is actually the impetus for the infamous
Burke and Hare murders that occurred in Scotland
during the 19th century.)
That said, corpus deliciti did exist which
is a similar concept to this “no body, no
murder” idea, but in this case a physical
body is not actually required.
You just need sufficient evidence that a murder
occurred, which may include an actual body,
but could also simply be testimonial evidence.
Essentially, you just needed a body of evidence
to show a murder had taken place, rather than
an actual physical body being required, which
is perhaps where the aforementioned apparent
“no body, no murder” misconception comes
from.